it happens pretty much all the time
a small jabbing comment a joke at our
expense amidst a group of old friends a
line of sarcasm a sneering assessment a
provocative comment on the Internet
these things hurt a lot more than we're
ever allowed to really admit in the
privacy of our minds we search for
explanations but anything satisfying and
soothing is usually hard to come by
which is left a puzzle at the casual in
humanity that circulates all around us
and suspect that perhaps it's we who are
somewhere deep down to blame for falling
victim to it here is what we should
actually think a truth as basic as it is
inviolable other people have been nasty
because they are in pain the only reason
they have hurt us is because they are
somewhere deep inside hurting themselves
they've been catty and derogatory and
foul because they are not well however
outwardly confident they may look
however virile and robust they may
appear their actions are all the
evidence we need that they cannot in
truth be in a good place
no one solid would ever need to do this
the thought is empowering because
nastiness so readily humiliates and
reduces us it turns us into the small
damaged party without meaning to we
begin to imagine our bully as potent and
even somehow impressive their
vindictiveness demeans us but the
psychological explanation of evil at
once reverses the power dynamic it's you
who has no need to belittle who is in
fact a larger steelier more forceful
party you who feel so defenseless who is
all along actually in power the thought
restores justice it promises that the
guilty party has after all been punished
along the way you might not have been
able to write the scales personally they
left the room already or kept the
conversation flowing too fast for you to
protest and in any case you're not a
sort to make a fuss but a kind of
punishment has been delivered cosmically
already somewhere behind the scenes
their suffering of which their needs to
inflict suffering on others is simply
incontrovertible evidence
is all you need to know that they have
been served their just desserts you move
from being a victim of crime to being an
audience to an abstract form of justice
they may not be apologizing to you but
they haven't escaped freely either their
sulphur is proof they are paying a heavy
price this isn't merely a pleasant story
a person who feels at ease with
themselves can have no need to distress
others we don't have the energy to be
cruel unless and until we are in inner
torment along the way the theory gives
hints at how we might when we've
recovered from the blow deal with those
who dealt it the temptation is to get
Stern and cruel back but the only way to
diminish the vicious cycle of hate is of
course to address its origins which lie
in suffering there is no point punching
back we must as the old prophets always
told us learn to look upon our enemies
with sorrow pity and when we can manage
it a forgiving kind of love
you